bien el vídeo pasado estuvo muy largo
espero que me hayas entendido ese último
problema intente acabarlo en el vídeo
pasado para que de una vez
tuviéramos la solución y no dividirlo
entre dos vídeos y si te hiciera confuso
ahora si no entendiste muy bien qué fue
lo que pasó en el vídeo pasado házmelo
saber ponlo en los comentarios
y podemos ver si hacemos ese problema en
un único vídeo pero bueno creo que
realmente no fue tan difícil el problema
pasado y vamos a seguirle estamos ahora
en el problema número 8 el problema
número 8 y dice el precio de un cierto
café mexicano es de de pesos por cada 8
kilogramos ok a ver déjame ponerlo aquí
por cada de pesos por cada de pesos
nosotros compramos 8 kilogramos nosotros
encontramos el creo kilogramos de este
café ok y si con cada kilogramo hacemos
se tasas de café ok eso también lo
podemos apuntar
por cada kilogramo por un kilogramo de
café nosotros hacemos zetas de café de
tasas
ok en términos de c y d en términos de c
y d de de i d c ok cuál es el precio en
pesos de una taza de café ok vamos a ver
que tenemos nosotros tenemos que con un
kilogramo de café hacemos tazas y con de
pesos compramos 8 kilogramos de café
vamos a apuntarlo esta parte de arriba
me dice que con de tasas con de pesos
perdón
nosotros hacemos 8 kilogramos de café 8
kilogramos de café ahora cuántas tazas
nosotros hacemos con 8 kilogramos de
café bueno pues con 8 kilogramos de café
nosotros vamos a hacer a sí con un
kilogramo hacemos de tazas con 8
kilogramos vamos a hacer 8 por c tazas
de café tazas de café tazas de café ok
esto matemáticamente lo podríamos
escribir como qué
pesos de pesos nos dan es exactamente lo
mismo que 86 tazas de café tazas de café
y si nosotros queremos despejar una sola
taza queremos saber cuánto vale una sola
taza en términos de y después hay que
despejar de aquí a tasas y para esto qué
te parece si divido ambos lados entre 80
es decir tienen una taza una taza de
café lo voy a conseguir con de pesos con
de pesos ya esto lo voy a dividir entre
8 sep entre 8 cm este este de aquí lo
pasé dividiendo del otro lado de esta
ecuación y ya está una taza de cuesta de
pesos entre 8 cm lo cual es el inciso a
es el inciso am y creo que estuvo muy
fácil así que vamos a hacer el problema
número 9 el problema número 9 que me
dices lo siguiente si 10
/ a es lo mismo que de entre 12 cuánto
vale
aborden bueno pues este problema está
muy fácil lo único que tenemos que hacer
es multiplicar a cruzado y si
multiplicamos cruzado éste se va a ir
para acá
ok y por otra parte éste se va a ir para
acá ok y me va a quedar que que 10 por
12 10 por 12 es lo mismo que aporte que
aporte que es justo lo que queremos o
dicho otra manera a por d es exactamente
lo mismo que 120
así de fácil está este problema hasta si
más extraño de hecho hay otra forma de
resolverlo nosotros podemos partir de
aquí 10 sobre a es lo mismo que de entre
12 y ahora multiplicar de ambos lados de
esta igualdad ahora lo podemos hacer en
pasos lo voy a multiplicar por am y lo
voy a multiplicar por a de tal manera
que ésta y ésta se van y me queda
solamente 10 es lo mismo que
por de entre 12 paso multiplicando estos
dos y ahora qué te parece si multiplicó
por 12 ambos lados de esta igualdad 12
por este y esto por 12 de tal manera que
éste se va a cancelar con este y ahora
si ya tengo despejado a x men aporte es
igual al 12 por 10 lo cuales 120 ok
problema muy fácil estamos corriendo en
tiempo así que vamos el siguiente
problema problema número 10 y dice
tenemos la sucesión 150 ok 30 ok
6,7 etcétera etcétera y dice en la
siguiente sucesión cada término es su
quinto el término anterior es un quinto
del término anterior es decir aquí lo
dividió entre 5
aquí lo dividir entre 5 o lo multiplique
por un quinto y aquí también lo
multiplique por un quinto lo multiplique
por un quinto lo que me preguntan es
cuál es el quinto término de esta
sucesión bueno pues aquí tengo mi
término 1
ok me termino 2 y terminó 3 como podemos
sacar el término 4
bueno pues tomamos este 6 y lo dividimos
entre 5 o lo multiplicamos por un quinto
6 por un quinto esto es lo mismo que 6
quintos ok
este es mi cuarto término ahora si yo
quiero el quinto término que es justo lo
que me piden a este término de aquí lo
tengo que dividir en 35 o multiplicar
por un quinto seis quintos por un quinto
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 6 sobre
25 y esta es mi respuesta 6 sobre 25 o
si lo quieres ver de una forma decimal
pues solamente tendremos que tomar los 6
entre 25 y aquí no cabe ninguna vez
entonces pongo un 0.60 cabe dos veces 2
por 25 50 y cuando no resto me da 10 ok
bajo un cero y me cabe cuatro veces es
decir que 6 entre 25 es lo mismo que
0.24
24 y esta es la respuesta de este
problema 0.24 6 sobre 25 que raro llevan
varios problemas muy sencillos
creo no sé vamos a seguirla vamos a
seguirle porque recuerda que tenemos que
darnos prisa viene problema número 11
problema número 11
vamos a ver si siguen siendo problemas
sencillos 5 puntos a bs the end están en
una recta y no forzosamente en ese orden
ok eso es importante 5 puntos a veces de
estar en una recta no forzosamente en
este orden y me dicen la longitud de la
abm la longitud de ave es lo mismo que
después me dicen que ese es su punto
medio
ok mejor de una vez dibujemos los a ver
tomémonos esta herramienta ok
tengo por aquí a mi recta numérica no
está en una recta y ahora imagínate que
por aquí yo a éste lo nombró a a este lo
voy a nombrar am ya estoy acá lo voy a
nombrar ve y lo que me dicen es que la
distancia de entre 20 es 24 así que
vamos a marcar la la distancia de entre
ven hagan con este cuadra me gusta esta
distancia de aquí hasta que toda esta
distancia es 24 y por una parte me dicen
que ese es el punto medio entre estos
dos así que por aquí por aquí va a estar
se y como se es el punto medio entre
estos dos entonces podemos decir que la
distancia que hay de aquí hasta acá pues
es la mitad de 24 lo cual es 12 y la
es la mitad de 24 en lo cual es 12
y después me dicen que d es el punto
medio entre s es decir que justo que a
la mitad por aquí tenemos a de i d es el
punto medio entre s dicho de otra manera
a la distancia que hay de aquí hasta acá
son seis unidades la distancia que hay
aquí hasta acá son seis unidades que es
la mitad de 12 ok si después me dicen
que es el punto y está a cinco unidades
de de ok el punto en estas cinco
unidades de puede estar para acá
ok o puede estar para acá me dicen cuál
es uno de los posibles valores de la
distancia de a jane o sea que por aquí
no puedo encontrar a él o por acá no
puedo encontrar
y yo lo que quiero es la distancia d ok
suena un poco engorroso todo esto así
que imagínate que olvidas todo lo que te
acabo de decir lo último que te acabo de
decir y vamos a quedarnos con este
esquema de aquí como esto me lo
entendiste bien vamos a enfocarnos
solamente en a dice solamente en lo que
hay entre dice ok a nuestro no me gusta
vamos a cambiar de color y vamos a
enfocarnos solamente entre dice ok
mediante que esta es mi recta numérica y
por aquí voy a tener el punto am por
aquí
este es mi punto a por acá este es mi
punto ce y yo sé que mi punto medio de
estos dos es de esos y me dice el
problema que el punto medio entre estos
dos este de kim es d
ok además sabemos que de a a b hay una
distancia de aquí acá hay una distancia
de 6 unidades y de aquí acá también hay
una distancia de 6 unidades
ok después me dicen que hay un tal punto
en esto es importante este punto en esta
a cinco unidades de tema
es decir que si nosotros vemos cinco
unidades de dm podemos llegar aquí y
aquí puede estar el punto el ojo no
podemos llegar a ser porque desde hace
hay seis unidades
no podemos pasar así porque habrían más
de seis unidades y sabemos que la
distancia de de jaén son cinco unidades
ok de aquí acá hay cinco unidades o
puede estar también del otro lado estás
de acuerdo
por aquí podría estar en y nosotros
sabemos que la distancia que hay de ave
son cinco unidades ahora lo malo es que
no nos dicen si él está a la derecha
desde
está a la izquierda de por lo tanto
podemos tener dos lugares porque estemos
a la derecha tenemos a la izquierda de
de ok y ahora pensemos en la distancia d
si te das cuenta tenemos dos posibles
distancias o tenemos esta distancia de
aquí esta podría ser una de ellas o la
otra es que tengamos toda esta distancia
de aquí podríamos empezar aquí y tener
la distancia de aquí hasta acá de aquí
hasta acá también podría ser otra
posibilidad de la distancia de aaee todo
depende en donde esté posicionado el
pero como no sabemos pues vamos a
calcular las dos distancias ahora de una
manera muy rápida tú me puedes decir que
la distancia que hay d
ay si está justo aquí es 1 porque de
aquí a acá hay 6 unidades y de aquí a
acá hay 5 unidades por lo tanto lo que
me resta esto sería una unidad ok
entonces la distancia de la aee puede
ser
una unidad o una unidad
y está a la izquierda a la izquierda
de de ok pero si estamos en la derecha
tendríamos toda esta distancia de aquí
hasta acá y cuánto hay de aquí hasta acá
bueno sabemos que de aquí hasta acá
hasta de hasta aquí tenemos seis
unidades y después de de ahí hay cinco
unidades más por lo tanto aquí tendremos
otras cinco unidades en total tendríamos
de seis a cinco lo cual son once
unidades de a hay amplia 11 unidades si
en esta a la derecha de de o también
podría ser 11 sí
está
está a la derecha derecha
y esta es mi respuesta podemos tener una
distancia de 1 o una distancia de 11
según donde esté en ok nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo